I thought you were personally
communicating with me when you made the
decision in these Hobbit movies to have
red hair I think that was you talking
through the movies and think we have a
picture here to me and saying this
arrows coming your way Conan right
obviously I'm bringing red back baby but
I kind of think that red is really sexy
especially on women particularly young
women okay that sounds that sounds like
you're saying not on men right Y on
women to the exclusion of men I just
like a red-haired woman that's all okay
that's all I'm saying well I'm very as
men go I'm very feminine so yeah it is
coming back though the red hair you
think I hope so yeah I hope so I'd like
to see a lot more red hairs out there
yeah red haired people yeah red hairs
out there just sounds like less
manscaping yeah I am i right you pick we
just saw that photo that you personally
picked your elfin ears for The Hobbit
movies you picked those ears because you
wanted them to be larger than the normal
elephant ears is that right yeah I was
kind of having a pissing contest with
Orlando Bloom and I was like I'm gonna
have the biggest years of middle-earth
and they were beautiful so you actually
said make me the big bigger bigger they
gave me three options they gave me a
small a medium and large and I said I
want the big ones they said no you've
got a very small phase let's try on the
small ones and I said I really want the
big ones okay we'll try the medium and
eventually they finally relented and I
did have the biggest ears in
middle-earth and you are that's quite an
achievement you you take that leg who
leggy
leggy come on who know who am I talking
about
he's way too cool Legolas Orlando
Bloom's carrot Thanks Legolas oh I've
never been more proud not to know
something of course I just call him
Orlandi do you you picture Kurtis ears
because you're a little bit ear obsessed
in real life aren't you how do you know
that because I read a little article
about you and I do my research talking
yeah in real life you know I don't worry
earrings odd I don't know if anyone ever
noticed that because I really I have a
thing where I play with my ears all the
time especially if I'm nervous or if I'm
tired or if I'm stressed out then I'll
start to just play with my ears and next
thing you know my ear will be folded
inside of my head that's horrifying
that's you just pushed your ear into the
individual slightly less attractive now
know that made no difference at all but
and I'm always checking out people's ear
lobes to see if they've done yeah well
really get in there get in there that's
nice oh my god oh my god juicy and big
[Music]
[Applause]
you have fantastic loaves thank you
told you Conan mine gets bigger if you
just keep
[Music]
that was humiliating for me
you really do what is it you like about
the earlobe um you know it's just a
comforting thing like when I was a
little girl God okay please continue
okay when I when I was a little girl I
don't know why I just I needed comfort
and a lot of it so I I would suck my
thumb
you know as a lot of little kids to you
that's pretty common and I would also
pull on my eyelid because I like the
feeling of the air on my eyeball and I
reach across one here
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I love anyone turning out right now yeah
at that moment not knowing what happened
right there I would have spent a that
was good yes Rios it was for me well yes
it was it was everything it was better
for you yeah great
turning to your real lover a alright
we're gonna take a quick break I have to
process what happened let more of
Evangeline Lilly in just a second stick
around
[Applause]
you